hello everyone thanks for joining me
today in my talk about how would we
build a cloud infrastructure as a code
with the fit for my name is for some
work out and I work as a technical lead
the company here at Sydney Australia
called William this is my twitter handle
if you would like to follow me or reach
out to me with any questions my agenda
for today is to talk about this
infrastructure as a code how would we
build the infrastructure as a code with
a quorum or to talk today which is below
me then we'll learn about the name
concepts that everyone is using premier
has to be aware of after that we will
see how will the provision the resources
required to create a silver list
application and then touch on how would
we integrate the Lummi with a continuous
delivery pipeline
finally we wrap up with think about
testing the infrastructure code written
by the pipe loop so let's kick of thing
is by talking about infrastructure as it
were historically we used to host our
application centers and we where we had
the server's the racks and everything in
there but with the rise of the cloud
computing
most of us started moving or leakage
from those physical data centers into
the cloud and his coat was doing as we
have seen in the keynotes
but the very first question that we we
were facing when we started moving our
applications to the cloud booth how
would I provision my resources how would
I create that virtual machine at the
finish system or how would I create my
whip app and the first answer to that
question was just point and click
you open the azure portal or AWS portal
you click on a button to say I'll let
the provision a virtual machine you feel
a bunch of properties and few minutes
later you have a whip app or a virtual
machine or whatever resources you would
provisioning but after a while I
realized done that because the
provisioning of resources memory we
usually end up with what's called
snowflake servers which is basically a
servers that each one is represented
with slightly different configurations
so if I have an application and that
application has multiple environments
let's say I have development staging
production and I'd like to provision my
application across all of those
environments if I provision two servers
manually each one of them will have a
slightly variance in their which usually
leads to troubles like something is
working on my development environment
but not on production or the other way
so let me this has a community to start
moving into what's called infrastructure
as a code and when we started working
with infrastructure as a code we had the
very first approach the idea behind
infrastructure as a code this is pretty
simple you just provision the resources
using code so this gives us a lot of
consistency and like you can provision
the same resources again and again again
so you have this reliability with
provisioning resources you can reproduce
the same outcome multiple times and the
first approach when we started working
with infrastructure as equals
the imperative approach so we're using
like the as your CLI or either be a city
lie or anything like that in addition
with passive scripts to provision very
sources so if we had a virtual machine
to provision I will just write a command
to provision that virtual machine but
with a more complex application we
usually have a lot of commands to
provision the resources so I might end
up with a better script or chef portion
script with like 40 or 30 50 comments
but this introduced a bit of a challenge
it have overcome a bunch of the
challenges in terms of reproducing the
same resources but what if one of the
commands failed how would I handle the
error of that command like if the
command number 30 out of 50 commands as
a script how would I make sure that I
have proper error handling in there so I
don't end up with inconsistent
environment also how would I help
idempotency so after I fix the issue
that I had in my application I can rerun
the whole script to recreate one of the
resources that I have in my environment
without having duplicate resources
so Lucy challenges make the strips
harder to meet in because with every
command I have to have idempotency error
handling and if we think about tearing
down those resources so if I have a
development environment and I no longer
when I use this environment I basically
need to write another script to tear
down so as an industry it's come for us
to abstract these kind of common
problems and that's what we have done by
abstracting only whose common issues
idempotency error handling provisioning
and updates to existing resources by
using a process called declarative
infrastructure as a flow and idea behind
the curative infrastructure as a gold is
abstracting all of those Unser's
idempotency error handling into the tool
so I end up as developer writing a
script to describe the desire and at the
stage so I only describe I have a
virtual machine and that virtual machine
will have inside of it like I would have
that amount of CPU and that amount of
memory and it's up to do all of the
logic to observe what needs to happen to
the cloud what mass needs to be called
the provision that virtual machine and
if we look at the current egg industry
we will find a lot of tools that help us
achieve this declarative infrastructure
physical approach such as as a resource
manager in a BS CloudFormation
Google deployment manager and the most
famous one is beautiful
Roderick was the the tech lead on the
Apollo moon landing project she built
all the software that took Neil
Armstrong Buzz Aldrin and the rest of
the Apollo astronauts to the moon and
brought them back sir
sorry
he will so we have terraform and
telephone is the most famous to right
now because it supports multiple clouds
and it's also a open source but the
problem that I face when I was working
with this tool is basically most of
those tools were written in Yemen files
for JSON files or something like this
flange - I'm coming from a development
background and I don't keep me resources
over those scripts and deal with a
little bit of trouble when I try to
maintain those resources and the other
thing that was also didn't make sense or
wasn't intuitive for me is she
introduced to the my Africa for loops
good thing I'm not really part of that
range sharp edges inside of it and if
you spend a lot of time you will
definitely be turned with one of those
pages and you can look into that website
that's go Yemen it has a lot of funny
things in there thanks to Jeff Huntley
who put it together but you will find a
lot of things so one of the sharp edges
and all of the things that were inject
to Yemen to come up with one of those
constructs it's it's really harder to
maintain over time but the good news is
thanks to the new me there is a
different way that we can provision
infrastructure as a tool without the
need to write over or learn all of those
Yemen or Jason or the mini specifically
so I would like to show you what is what
is to me is all about me is an open
source infrastructure as a crude it
enables us to write infrastructure code
in C sharp or typescript
or go to we can provision of the cloud
resources that we need and the benefits
of that are a lot so think about if
like to write a for loop or an if
condition it's part of the language
nothing new to be learned in there if I
would like to if I find a piece of
functionality that's kind of a common
and can be used in other teams in my
company I can start doing abstractions
and share those abstractions using my
favorite package manager if I'm using
javascript or JavaScript I can go with
NPM in.net I can go newbie packages and
it's C short or a type of script I can
use my IDE that I'm used to with all of
the themes all of the shortcuts I can do
refactoring with the patient static type
checking rules are just built in things
it's all that problem you don't have to
reinvent solutions for this problem I'm
fine I'm meeting with unit testing if
I'm working in the text I can use
something like X here it or in unit so
the video animation destroying the audio
quality I think we don't have any more
animation so that shouldn't be an issue
so the those are the kind of benefits
that we have in there so let me jump
into the terminal and show you how we
actually build our very first movie
application
in order to use Badou me the very first
thing we need to do is in a student
Silla I called balloonist and to create
a bill on the application you run
blooney
you this will show us all of the plaits
can use to provision blue lumi works
across multiple clock I'll soon see here
AWS as your GCP and even kubernetes
today's talk will be using Azure and
seashore but as you can see you can use
the blooming with other clouds and even
with Japanese you will use as you see
sharp blue miss you know I will ask me a
set of properties about my projects that
I'm trying to provision so I'll go with
blue me one description of the project
what is the stack think of the stack as
if it's an environment so if you have a
development staging pre prod this is a
stack so I'll keep it just development
and when we my resources be hosted I'm
living in Sydney Australia so I'll use
this trillion east this is the closest
to me what will happen right now is
lunacy aligned with provision
I don't need core 3.1 console
application and let's zoom into the
visual aesthetic code to see what are
the content of that application so it's
simple to fit core 3.1 and it has and
you get package installed inside the
ribs your middle asset and this is the
package that enables us to describe the
desired state of power resources you
have a ml file I know it's there is an
alligator you can get away from Yemen
but the good thing is we are not
injecting it in front of those if
conditions for loops radius variables
and everything the key value of this
file is because we only supports
multiple runtimes need to know what kind
of run time our project is built with
the next file is a configurations of my
environment because I might be used a
different location of the resources for
the development
the development team in Australia but
the actual users of the applications are
living in us so I can change this
configuration similar things can be done
with amount of CPU the amount of memory
and any other configurable values that
I'm gonna have across to my specs
the next thing is we have a program and
it's one-liner it's using a class from
the Lummi package
it's deployment the step inside
the step loss this is women actually
define very sources of the application
so we can either plus that inherits from
a stack and it's a it's not the spec
structure it's just a class called a
stack from bloomie and in the
constructor of this last we go and
create our resources and give the
resources by just creating a new
instance of the resource so imagine if
you haven't is a container for resources
so we create a resource at you and in
this resource see who this is
with this new innocence I will go and
provision a storage account so creating
a storage account in agile is just a new
instance of that account cloth I wanna
change the properties of that account we
are just set of properties that I pass
to my close instructor and the good
thing since this is a statically typed
language if I write something wrong I
will immediately get this feedback loop
with this red squiggly that I have
written something wrong I cannot confine
my application and because still I
static is technically type and I am in
c-sharp I can easily get code completion
out of the books the last thing that I
will show you here in this generated
code is the idea of the output
properties once I have a connecticut
once i have storage accounts i need to
have the connection string so i can give
that connection string to my application
so that my application can start a
clothing files to that storage account
and so the body
of the connection string will only be
available after the storage account has
been actually provisioned into Azure so
after I get the connection string I need
to actually write this as an output of
my application so I can copy that output
pass it to my application so that it can
start uploading find save and we do this
by creating this generic type called
output output means that the value of
this property will only be available
after the resource has been provisioned
and we want to take it with the output
attribute which those two things we mean
that the value of this property will be
printed to the console after the
resource has been published and we set
the value of this property it's just a
normal property we set the value of it
as as an outcome of the storage account
property called primary connection strip
so it's a straightforward however if you
have more resources as we will see later
it becomes very handy to have those kind
of properties so let's go improve vision
very sources that we have in each
reduced by using velu me up once we
don't blow me up Romi we do previewing
of the resources that will be
provisioned if I were to go with go
ahead and actually provision and those
resources so right now I'm expected to
see a resource room and the storage
account sitting inside this resource of
you it usually takes a few seconds there
we go we have the plan of the resources
that will be professional if I go ahead
and say yes this will actually go and
provision both resources and in the way
if you're wondering help luminous help
which has an account to connect to if
you are running on your local machine
and you are looked into your as your CLO
I'll let me will respect those criminals
credentials pick them up from the pick
the default subscription that you have
and we connect to that subscription same
thing happens with other class or like
AWS or any other if we are in a CI
environment you
not be looked into that as a CLI so I
can plus those values or credentials to
bloomie using environment valuable that
that it can pick it up from so here we
go the resources has been provision for
us the status of civil and storage
account and the output was the
connection history if I would like to
change the resource of one of the
resources rigidly if this was an
imperative code I have to check if the
resource exists in the value from this
to that
but with below me I don't need to do
anything apart from just changing the
desired State
so if I want to change the storage
account from standards let's say to
premium I just change it in here once I
do this and then I get back let's clear
this up safe Lumi this will show us that
one resource needs to be updated
and the resources who doesn't need to be
updated because it's already there and
they didn't do any changes to that
resource it's still going through the
previewing phase and there we go we only
have one change happening in there and
it's changed to that storage icon so
let's go ahead and proceed with updating
the storage account this will go replace
the storage account and print the new
connection string and if I switch to the
other portal just to show you that the
resources has been provisioned this is
going from the provisioning facelets
there if i refresh i can see that there
is the resource group has been
provisioned for me the thing to notice
here is this there is this unique string
at the end of the resources room this is
part of the paluma features because if
you would like to get multiple demands
and you want to have collision between
the resources
Lumi automatically add this unique thing
at the end of the resources we have
controlled to not do this if we don't
like to as I will show you in the next
step right now I'm expecting the
resources to do it so if I jump a game
to the resource igloo I will see both
resources has been provisioned one of
them with two storage accounts and now
cause one delete it and it's only one
has been created and this is the premium
account they just update if we ended up
with the case that I don't I no longer
need to see I would like to just destroy
them or tear them down I just use
bloomie strong-ass bloom illustrate
those resources ask for a confirmation
go ahead and bam we are done with
hitting down all of the resources that
has been provision so let's get back to
the slides and go through a comparison
between bloom and the value of this
comparison is to see how much you need
to learn if you were to go in telephone
versus Peru so in the left hand side is
a terraform script so if I would like to
provision or create a resource if you I
need to learn the syntax of creating any
resource inside tariff or with this
resource resource name search type
resource name which is the location
however in c-sharp of type scriptura
it's just a new instance if I want to
define a variable of the type array I
need to learn this syntax of the
variables and this specific file that
was list however in c-sharp it's just an
array no nothing to learn there if I'm
gonna loop over through this array and
to provision a storage account pair each
item I need to learn how how to use this
counting I need to learn how to read
from a variable and it's helpful to use
a resource ago like how to use it how to
access another resource but in c-sharp
it's just a new instance with a string
interpolation no magic in there so as
you can see if you are coming from a
development background the learning
curve is
it's much much less compared to
terraform or even worse if you were to
go with younger or like Jason or
anything like that we quickly go through
the key fundamentals that you have to be
aware of when you are working with
blooney as we have seen one of the core
things in plumie is a project a project
is basically any directory that has the
blue needle xeon phi usually carry the
project using the plumie new command
the next thing is the stakes my
application could have multiple stacks
like development uet and production so
if I would like to have different
configurations across different stats I
can do this by using will you need stack
in it this we create the stack and then
I can set the different configurations
of each environment by using Yui config
sit would I give it the key and then I
give it a value so what's it called
Paloma come fix it what will happen is
it will automatically update the
environment stack ml file and this will
set the key of the that I have provided
with its value and I can access the
value of this is that while using Lumi
that conflict and conflict does require
just creating a new instance and reading
the values from that template file
however as you can see database password
is something sinston so I'm not gonna
save this in a more secure way and in
order to save secrets inside p.m. and
5:00 you usually do this by passing and
then the command sorry that flag secret
when I'm setting the coffin and this
will save an encrypted value or included
value based on your environment
configurations if you are saving
Zeus ml files locally the default will
be just importing them however there are
options to encrypt the those values also
if you don't wanna access those or save
those values inside the ml file and
access them directly maybe continuous
delivery pipeline you can
to do this inside the pipe lot the next
thing that they wanna cut is working the
C sharp or type script or gold you could
give us the feeling that Ruby is
actually more of an imperative rather
than declarative well good actually
believe me is a still declarative even
though we are creating a new instances
Bologna is a standard and I'd love to
show you this by looking under the hood
of help lumi actually works when we have
a new resource that is written in our
code we passed this resource to the
plumie CLR and the very first thing that
Louisiana I do is look up the value
inside the state so the value inside the
state is the current set of resources
it's a snapshot of the resources that
has been provisioned and at the very
beginning this file would be empty
nothing inside the state so you can see
here the code represents the desired
state state represents the current and
the very finished step when we go with
blue material and when we say up and go
through the planning phase and the
outcome of the planning phase is basic
need a dependency graph of the resources
that needs to be provisioned and it's a
dependency graph because we wanna know
the sequence when we will provision the
resources so as we have seen in the last
time I had a resource group that will
include storage account so access to
provision the resource if you first had
been provision the storage account also
the dependency graph helps Lumi to
determine the some source of parallelism
if possible wines provisioning very
sources the next phase is taking this
dependency graph passing it into the
next phase which is apply and applying
we will basically take the outcome of
that planning phase and start calling
the actual cloud providers like AWS or a
ship to create update or delete
resources after the resources are
created we get back and update our state
so the next time we'll get back to or
update our desired State
the plumie said I can determine the
Delta between in the desire and the
current state so this approach means
that plume is a still a declarative
approach and it's not comparator and if
you compare this approach with something
like beautiful
you will find it's working pretty much
the same way so the approach is pretty
much the same so this is giving us the
kind of the best of both holding having
a declarative approach but still I'm
using all of the benefits of statically
typed language with the refactoring
intelligence and everything so let's
switch gears angle and see how would we
actually provision a little bit more
complicated application so I wanted to
create small application and that the
application has three resources I have a
repair it's a single page application
that I would like to host inside a
storage account and then that would
application will be calling a set of
api's that are implemented using other
functions if either function is a server
lish boxset release function and that
server this function is similar to AWS
lambda that function will be saving if
data into silver list database called
cosmos DD so this is pretty much that
what I wanted to provision so it doesn't
sound complicated but as me we see that
number resources required to provision
this application is a lot the first one
is a storage account we have seen this
last time
pretty easy straightforward and done but
then I started looking into how the
provision Kosmos DP I thought of it that
to provision the cosmos DP I need to
provision three resources
Osmos account sequin database and the
container container think of it like a
table it's not related but think of it
this way just to make it easy
the next thing is provisioning the agile
function app and this is where things
became very very interesting to me
because I found that I have to provision
the function f I need to provision an
app service plan and that app service
plan
we have something called function app
and the function f requires storage
account to save some information about
that function app and the function have
also lists know where is that code that
it will execute and that code that will
be executed it's gonna be hosted as a
plot inside the container inside the
storage account so as you can see the
number of resources has started to get
bigger and bigger and the dependencies
started to get more complicated let's
see how do me help us provision all of
those resources while we are maintaining
the application and making it sure that
it's easily easily maintainable
application let me switch yeah alright
good so this is our application the
thing that we wanted to provision is the
storage account the static website so we
have seen this in the last demo I can
eat a storage account and I just passed
few other properties
remember that unique stream that we have
at we had at the end of the resourcing
you I can't change this globally what
can I change it very smooth so in this
case that if I want to set a specific
name I can just pass the property name
to my account argument and the same
thing for the storage group if I pass
the exact name in this case expand this
I can see that I can sit I have a prefix
for my application
and then I have this technique so my
application is a team timezone - the 14
time zone
- uet and so on however after I clearly
the storage accounts storage accounts
and added enables us to host static
websites however we can't really set a
property that's called like static
website equal true there is no such
thing
it's not available for us yet it's not
available in as your erm it's not at the
lumen limitation it's just an edge of
limitation so if I was working in any
other environment that's not blue B I
had to paint my infrastructure code was
some imperative or restrict to actually
go and call as your API set this
property
however since I'm inside C sharp I can
add them you get package of the azure
storage make go to that API set this
property and that's what we are doing in
here I've I have this method that's
called enable a static website in here
I'm just using the azure and you get
package set that property of a static
website to true and I have a bit of a
logic in here make sure that I don't
execute this philandering the preview
phase because my function requires the
connection string which will only be
available after the resource has being
already provisioned once I have this
method I thought how would I call it
because the connection string is not
available to me yet
Lumi offer this method that's called
apply which you can call in any output
variable and plumie will trigger the
lambda method which is a parameter of
this apply with the with the actual
value of the output variable so after
the resource has been provisioned the
apply call was triggered my enable a
static website with the value of the
Canisius tree so the key point here is I
didn't have to change context between
c-sharp and like powershell goes like
arm template and powershell or arm
template and something else I don't need
switch context it's just one application
one infrastructure as a code approach so
there is no context switching over here
so after I provision the static website
I don't head with provisioning the
Kosmos DP and it was be honest was
pretty straightforward
they are just three resources
Osmos TP account database that is using
that cosmas DP accounts was announced
and then we have a container which is
hosted inside the database I know her
using a lot of regions in here and
they're using behind that is the code is
started to get a little bit bigger and I
don't use regions in my production code
I'm using it here for the demo to make
it easy for you to follow so if it hit a
nerve or something overall it hurts your
eyes
this is Peter with me we will get rid of
them shortly so in order to like start
getting things back on track in terms of
the lines of code and building
credibility all right how about you
start by refactoring this code to a
method so how they extract those three
resources into a method and this is what
I have done actually the method but only
have those three resources so we go the
regions are gone and they only have the
resources in here and then I started
looking into alright this started to get
bitter
how would I provision so my code is just
much shorter now just one liner to
provision because most DP I would a
provision as your function the provision
that has your function I actually have
to provision five resources with a lot
of dependencies between them those
dependencies means I have a storage
account app service plan and one of them
just accepting a few parameters here and
there it is just need to know what you
need to provide them and this is just
normal
however after I just configured all of
those resources
I found a cane I cut out of nobility
zone and it's 141 lines of codes this is
getting a lot bigger and thinking about
about this as a function and the static
website I feel actually it might make
sense for other teams in my company but
they would be interested in reusing this
as a function and now every team has to
go and configure all of those resources
and same idea with aesthetic website the
if might be other people would like to
host single page application inside the
storage account and if they were to they
have to overcome the same issue with an
English static website so the good thing
is roomy itself enables us to introduce
abstractions into the application
so I started introducing a static
website abstraction and that static
website abstraction is basic editing
from a class called the component
research and once we do this we
introduce a new logical resource this is
nothing that would be provision it's
just a container for a set of resources
and I can provide parameters to my class
instructor and I have to call a base
constructor which is giving me like the
logical name of my source and passing
what is the name of the resource and
very social and all what I have in the
static website is the storage account
and the method of enabling a static
website which I have shown you
previously the good thing with this
abstraction is if any of my team members
reflect hosts
any single page application they would
just use this new resource that's called
the static website and once Microsoft I
provide us with this property I just
need to fix a property in this
abstraction and the consumers don't need
to worry about it it's just the code
from an ability still the same and the
same thing with the ID function I have
created a new logical resource which is
called archive function app by
inheriting from the component resource
copying all of the five resources that
are required to provision my either
function inside of this class so we have
a search account the app service plan
and the rest of the resources I have no
supervise a few sorry for the claim here
I have provided a lot of parameters to
my pleasure function app like the app
settings Buddhist massage
what is the prefix what is their sushi
group name they can add any because it
makes more sense so once I started
introducing loose kind of abstractions
my silent version of the code became
much more readable and I didn't have to
have any regions or anything like that
so this is the final version right now I
have a static right that's a nice horse
no magic in there I have a cosmos DB I
didn't create an abstraction over the
cosmos DP because it didn't resonate
well for this particular application and
this is something that we usually need
to think about when we are abstracting
resources because you don't want to kind
of have a lot of abstractions that are
unnecessary or that static website and
as a function add we made sense to me
however cosmos TV didn't make sense you
need to think about those abstractions
in your particular situation and finally
we have the other function which became
much much more smaller because I just
need to provide the specific parameters
that are relevant to that function and
once I saw this piece of code looking
like that it made it to me as if I'm
presenting my architecture this is how I
thought about my application when I
started when I started designing this
application I wanted to have an
application that has three resources
static website the total function app
which saved data into cosmos DB so as
you can see those kind of abstractions
helps us in terms of having an intent
revealing poop and the abstractions as
well with complex abstractions like
function app helps us to bring more
practice is a good practice from
networking and security into them so as
the developers we don't need to worry
about one of those kind of concerns when
we are consuming if I want to have a can
as your function egg or just one you
Edison's of a class and I'm done I
didn't need to think a lot about those
aspects because they already implemented
in the abstraction so far I won't
actually go up provisioned those
resources because if I did that it will
take like 15 minutes because of a lot of
resources has to be promised
but once they provision those resources
one of the things if you are using the
pillow me is offering you will give a
nice presentation of the provision
resources so plumie has this offering
like similar to the terraform enterprise
where you can manage all of the state of
more resources and you can see the stack
and the provisioned resources and as we
can see here it's showing me and graph
of the dependencies that I have
provisioned and with those abstractions
even plumie were able to show me a group
of those resources extracted in this new
kind of resource so this is my other
function this is my static website
Kosmos DP it wasn't abstracted so it's
shown it just immediately under my stack
so those kind of obstructions also
becomes handy in terms of understanding
how the application has been built and
how to get your head around it pasted so
far I've been showing you how would we
provision the resources from my CLI but
most of us wouldn't provision the
resources by using CLI we'd be using a
deployment pipeline and kotomi makes it
pretty easy to be integrated with any
pipeline I have to have a man code and
then I have the preview phase in the
preview phase I would have I'll select
this tank that I'm gonna provision and
then I don't pro me preview obviously I
need to provide the credentials by
environment variables and then I have
usually I have a manual step where I
just begin what kind of resources would
be generated updated or deleted in my
environment and this is usually like an
approval step once I approve that Pulu
me up we actually go and provision the
resources that I have asked if we
basically equals the outcome of the
preview phase the key thing that you
need to think about when you are
integrating Bluebeam is the deployment
pipeline is when would you save your
state file loot Mesa for saving in the
state file in multiple locations like
using their online offering or you can
save it in something like a storage
account AWS s3 whatever you choose you
need to make sure this file is saved in
a secure way because it will have
sensitive information inside of it such
as the connection string that we have
seen with the storage account so it's
pretty important to make sure that you
have the state file saved in a secure
place
the next thing that I will talk about is
the testing so after we have
infrastructure code written I would like
to verify that my code is actually
working as expected
similar to any other code and usually do
this with unit testing and integration
system unit testing in the context of
infrastructure as a code is you can
apply policies like I'm glad to make
sure that if I have a virtual machine it
doesn't open a port for remote desktop
as an example or all of the resources
has a product name as a tag
so I can run those tests without even
provisioning the resources whose it's a
statically typed language I can access
all of those properties while I'm
running the code locally the next aspect
is the integration testing with the
integration testing I would like to make
sure that if I run this application if
we actually provision the resources the
provisioning part is actually working
and after a provision unlikely to
inspect some of the properties of the
provision resources so this is where the
integration testing will come in handy
right now with premiere I can write unit
tests for my infrastructure as I could
in c-sharp as I will show you in a
second however I can't do this right now
with for the integration testing
integration testing there is a framework
for purely but sitting go right now
however for unit testing we can write it
in C shop so I'll show you here an
example how would I
make sure that all of the resource
groups in my application as a product me
as a tech the first thing we do is we
run a method here it's full of tests as
things this is just a utility method
that we go and run all of the resources
in memory like deployment around a sink
I don't return me all of the resources
and out of those resources I repaired
very saucy groups and those resource
groups I will find our verify that one
of them has a tag
oh that's called product me so this I
can start applying more policies like
axing as we said the port or having SSH
access or anything like that applying
things with the unit tests the key thing
to keep in mind that if you are working
with output variables the values of
those variables will not be available
during their listing because it's only
available after the resource has been
provisioned so you can't really verify
that the connection string property has
been it doesn't exist yet and this is
how you do the unit testing so let's
summarize what we have covered so far
Lumi is infrastructure as a code -
that's a force multiplier then it's an
open source tool
it only supports multiple languages
Seashore go and no J's it's a stellar
declarative language it's not imperative
although we are using the new instances
as we have seen the way plumie works
makes it still declarative language Lumi
has few key concepts that you need to be
aware of project which is any directory
that has a plumie HTML file a stack
which is similar it independently
configurable innocence when we have like
different configurations can be applied
I apply those configurations by ml files
and I can read them from the C shortcode
Lumi itself enables us to have
abstractions as we have seen with the
azure function and with a static website
these abstractions makes it easy to
share code with other
seems inside the organization so I can
package my class into a nougat package
and share it with other teams so they
can create other functions also clearly
makes it easy to integrate with
continuous delivery pipelines
if a better plumie itself has like
out-of-the-box tasks that integrates
with common plasmons like adjectives
oxalis deploy or jenkins and other other
environments this way and finally the
testing part gloomy enables us to write
unit testing and integration tests for
our infrastructure ethical unit tests we
can write it in c-sharp integration
systems not yet and I believe once you
start working with bloomie you will feel
that this is how the way you should
write infrastructure as a code because
if you are especially if you are coming
from a development background I don't
expect that you wouldn't have a lot of
learnings to do because there are few
concepts to cover in there and then you
are good to go create resources
abstractions and everything if you'd
like to learn more about bloomie the
they move that we have done today are
available to my github people I will
circle the resources in the section you
can think more about below me by looking
into the communication which is fairly
up-to-date and finally there is a big
gem which is a loonie examples I post
free it has heaps and heaps of examples
and it's not true like trivial examples
it has also a bit of complicated
examples with different languages with
different cloud environments and
everything finally the slides are
available by listening and I will also
share the slides over the sega channel
right now I'll just hand over to you if
you have any questions here in the chat
and I will also try to ping up the
YouTube channel to see if there is any
questions over there
see I'm just checking the YouTube
alright cool doesn't look like there is
a question there feel free to ask any
questions over the slack channel and
I'll answer them as as fast as I can
Thank You Natalie